find equational proof shouldn't PD
experimentalist okay well let me read
the argument now how perked read don't
proven for all first or logic okay yeah
I don't understand wife predicate
wouldn't be part of equational logic I
mean it well is it not that that's
that's the current plan so we're the the
function that was called fine predicate
proof
we're now integrating into find equation
of proof for twelve point one okay and
so what aspect to find equation or proof
should be considered experimental still
I mean that integration does it affect
the design applying equation or proof it
affects the design of the okay I know it
affects the design of the proof object
slightly because we have to add I mean
there are essentially two new kinds of
proof step that we're going to be adding
so what I mean that doesn't that would
not blow up the experimental icing and I
mean in the sense that that's just
adding functionality it does not effect
it does not invalidate the existing
design I mean is that there's also an
argument that we should the experimental
ice until we know what's going on with
the lien project but Jose's probably the
right person to make that argument Jose
what would you have to say about that
well that's still far in the future I
think there is a part of proof object
which is rather stable the fact that it
has its first three arguments and then
the fourth one it's very general we can
put whatever we want there what is the
form of Republic well I don't remember
its argument structure yes so there are
two arguments which are obvious which
are the the theorems you are trying to
prove the actions you start with and
then the first one is the logic you are
using to
I mean we're not documenting we're
documenting properties of proof object
we're not documenting the internal
structure the proof object here are we
no I probably not but but still I mean
you know it I'm I'm thinking that the
with respect to proof object I'm fairly
sure we have this great structure even
that the last argument is very general
okay let's look at what this is so the
fact that I'm saying functions with
names like managed crocodile is odd but
anyway okay so what is this here um
prove object predicate logic so that's
the base axiom system that's a logic we
are using to proof from transactions so
what are the other things that could be
in there well for example we want to add
the synthetic logic for synthetic
geometry I'm not sure what the name is
going to be but what is the difference
by understand this is the logic that's
being used I understand how that relates
to what do you mean by that I mean how
does it relate to the axiom system yeah
yes so the the form in which we write
the action system and the theorem we
want to prove will depend on there on
that first argument it has to match that
because that's that that first argument
will tell us what we can expect and what
we will do to construct the proof okay
but explain to me what's the difference
between the synthetic geometry thing I
mean they're all a bunch of statements
there's asserted to be true and so on
what's the difference between that and
the pro cat logic case
well in the predicate logic case we only
accept equalities and and the function
for symbols we will be using there while
in the synthetic logic case we will be
accepting a larger variety of things and
what other cases are there I don't
understand why the assertion what's part
of the base logic and what's part of the
axioms so I mean saying something is on
the midpoint you know this is on the
midpoint of is at the midpoint of that
seems like in the case of predicate
logic that would just be a managed
crocodile type function so to speak
what's the difference between managed
crocodile and is that the midpoint of
well they don't handle everything via
equalities for example then you have to
have statements of all the types and
predicate logic would not be able to
handle those okay but better than the
case silver go I don't see equalities
here either for all right so I think
it's worth noting that there's a there's
a subtlety in the in the predicate logic
case which is that there's a mismatch
between the logically used to define the
axioms in the theorem and the logic
that's actually used for the proof
because the way that the predicate logic
prove are works is you give it something
in first order logic and then it will
convert it into it's an echo satisfiable
thing in equational logic and then it
will prove that and so the so the the
the actual proof is is purely equational
but the logic for the that was used to
specify the axioms and the theorem is
first-order so wait a minute when we
look at but so the logic the
specification logic here is the same as
the synthetic geometry specification
logic correct because that's also
first-order is it or is it not I mean
you could convert it to that I I don't
know I mean right now this is the way
that the synthetic geometry works
doesn't involve converting it into the
first-order although it could like we
could use sort of tuskys axioms or
something I'm confused
until in the current case that a
geometry yeah the geometry is not using
for all and there exists its what is it
using instead of those it's implicitly
saying that isn't it I'd say so I think
it's it's implicit yes they have an idea
of points and what it's saying is for
all points a such that blah blah blah
this is true okay but in terms of what
Jonathan was saying that first argument
says they prove sorry the logic we used
to construct the proof not the logic in
which the statements are written because
that should be readable from the
statements themselves yes well unless we
want to carry around with the statements
um something about the logic in which
they're supposed to be I mean it's not
self-evident that there are no doubt
degenerate cases of some fancier logic
that look like a different kind of logic
if you just look at the statement right
so I mean like one thing we discussed
was having it as part of the proof
objects having an axiom logic and a
proof of prove logic that are not
necessarily the same boy that's pretty
weird but yes I understand that I mean
there's also the statement is made okay
so what you're saying is the statement
is made with respect to one kind of
logic then the proof could be done in
another kind of logic oh boy okay this
is kind of weird I think you're just
trying to confuse me enough that we'll
have to agree to not be experimental
iceless stuff um all right I mean I
guess that's okay I you know fine all
right we'll leave it experimental for
another version um I mean it's just
should consider that we have some
pressure to be experimental eyes we
don't just want to leave things
experimental for for ages all right okay
fine all right consider that anybody
want to disagree with that conclusion
okay all right
so be it okay I think is that everything
for Jonathan it's welcome to stick
around but it's probably everything
there Thanks okay see you later
do you want to move up to around first
the numbers fit uncertainty because Jose
is here fine okay oh you want to keep
this experimental why I'm absolutely yes
so I have a stronger opinions on this
one and the previous one so here I've
seen users quite happy about the
functions because they can do now what
they had to do what they need to do at
university excetera the main complaint
about around is is the handling of the
nonlinear case so around was constructed
on the idea that you want you are
interested in propagation of errors
linearly typically using the formulas so
most of the complaints have received are
things like oh it it fails at the
stationary points of trigonometric
functions or it fails at the cusp of
absolute function absolute value
function this type of thing so somehow
users expect some sort of blend between
this linear propagation error and a very
strict interval propagation what do they
mean by fails okay so let me just try to
understand what you're talking about so
you're saying that if I were to try
something like cosine of a run of zero
plus something so we are differentiating
at the maximum of cosine okay zero with
plus minus 0.3 or something like right
what the heck is that exactly
so because the
yes but you see the problem is here that
at that point we have derivative zero so
the standard formulas of propagation of
errors will say well because the
derivative is zero the error is zero
okay but stripping me around and not
leaving I understand I understand the
issue but well that's a different
different thing so a round of three plus
minus zero should mean just the number
zero so if I said like PI over two here
right so okay other points is fine but I
mean if you just say around the 1 comma
zero it will just say oh you mean the
number one this is this this was done
just to avoid having a new
representation of a number because
always a round of one comma zero is a
number mm-hmm I think this is wrong I
think that yes so that's my point we
should do something more intelligent
there but of course that would be a
breakage with this under formulas so we
would have to somehow explain well we
are not using the Sun but the standard
formula would say this is 1 plus or
minus 0 is that correct yes 0 because I
say because it's first-order errors
exactly but I mean if I say but look
look look I mean if I say plus or minus
4 or something here that's just crazy
because I mean that actual value could
be anything between minus 1 and 1 but
but now you see now you are thinking in
terms of interval propagation mm-hmm and
so that's what I mean so we have these
two paradigms and they do different
things in the in the nonlinear cases so
we need to flop what happens if I have a
higher order for I got a higher order
here how do i how do i specify that yes
you would have to use the second
argument for rank replies so you say
around replaced because by default
propagation is or is always order one so
you say exactly around replace cosine
and then X goes
yes and I think so yes X goes to a round
of 0 comma 3 and then the third argument
will be a two or three let's use for
example right so that's something which
is closer to what the users expect but
of course they have to go through this
and I've prepared these the answer here
is absolutely bonkers look at the answer
yes it's still it's still bad because
that's what the formulas to order 3 give
if you keep increasing these to order
infinity they would give better and
better results or than I mean we have
formulas up to order for because this
from lesser are hardwired but but even
that's pretty bonkers right I mean in in
um yes yes so so I'm not defending this
and I'm just explaining how it works and
why you should have complained and I
understand so so I understand we need
something else but I just I don't know
what it is how to blend continuously
these two interval preparation ok so one
thing is the first order effect and the
issue is at what point or nth order you
know expansion um and the question is at
what point does a Taylor expansion break
down basically right because in a sense
what they want is infinite order which
is just going to transform distribution
but then of course in most cases we
cannot do it I understand but I mean the
issue is I say the issue is even in the
case where the error is quite small
that's still going to be unhappy with
cosine just turning into one I think
what we could we could leave there round
1 comma 0 but but that that could create
problems somewhere else but yeah we can
look into that well around 1 comma 0
point might create less problems than 0
then then pure 0 right
I distinguish since the open frontier
yeah this is Rob here and does Rob have
an opinion about this yeah so we are
talking about error propagation in
around and there and the fact that it
follows the statistical formulas not the
interval propagation formula so it just
looks at the first few derivatives at
the point rather than trying to limit
intervals which means that in the case
of cosine because the first derivative
is zero it thinks that the error you
know it thinks that the error is zero so
people who've done error propagation in
you know standard kind of um what do
they do with this I mean cuz they just
get this wrong well if you go to the
standard documents like the gamma
document a guide of uncertainty by you
standards they express their first-order
formulas and then they say if you need
to go higher here you have the second
order from and then they leave it at
that
but what what is the second order okay
so another if they get it wrong they get
it wrong next one yeah so that's why I
went farther and computed and hardwired
fourth up to fourth order formula
because you get something but it's still
very wrong but still bonkers I mean that
that result is just completely crazy yes
yes but I mean at least it's hairy so we
can go if users ask what is that result
we can tell ok it's this formula right
it's your producible if we do something
else which I'm happy to do we have to
decide what it is I had to explain it
now it goes up to four
I have formulas before I'm not I'm not
doing that right my n is not there and
you think it is I'm just using the I
should call it D um
okay so that's the successive errors as
we increase the input error that's the
output error for the second-order
formulas for a round right and these are
just so if we do third order looks the
same because there's a second derivative
and presumably fourth order we'll start
to see a difference because there's a
non-vanishing fourth derivative is that
correct actually these are good examples
we should we should capture these
examples but but can I make a comment
here I mean that the whole this whole
first order second or a third or a thing
I mean by the time you get to deviations
of size greater than one that doesn't
mean anything yes yes but you could say
so that's that's users error in the
sense of being computing something that
doesn't make much sense but they still
want to compute well let it look they
measure some random truly measured thing
in particle physics where they only have
three events to determine whether some
you know dark matter particle exists or
something and then they feed that
through a cosine and suddenly the thing
turns the three events that they had
with huge errors and makes it a precise
value and then everything goes to hell
see what I'm saying yeah that's the bad
thing the bad thing is that you're being
you're being falsely because it's
first-order even though the error is
very big you're being lulled into I mean
clearly we can know there's a problem
okay so here's a way to think about it
take me around put it in the cosine and
look at the interval values that you get
out right we clearly can know what the
values were at the ends of the interval
from the around right if those interval
ah I mean okay that there's then a
predicted value from the derivative
formalism from the series expansion
right okay so if those are way different
something is wrong but if the if the
derivative formalism says the value
should be one but the interval formalism
says the value should be point eight or
something or minus point five or
something like this then you know
there's a problem
I mean I don't know you know so in other
words the way you could merge it is by
saying look at the interval see what the
values are at the end of all compare
those with values you get from the
series formalism and if they are more
different than something then I don't
know exactly what you do but then
probably what you do is you round up the
interval case round up the the series
case to blend in a certain amount of the
interval value I mean I think that's a
that's a way of smoothly interpolating
between in other words you can say
there's a critical value possibly a
critical value or possibly some sort of
blending type thing where you know
there's a deviation there's an implied
deviation at the endpoints of the
interval at the endpoints of the error
bar there's an implied deviation from
the value right um in in the output from
the function and the question then is
what you know how do those implied
deviations agree between series and
interval and I would claim there's
probably an optimal way if we think
about it so some optimal well what's the
obvious way to blend those things so I
mean clearly it would be is there a is
there a value to having consistency yeah
there's probably some value to having
consistency and this is only the case
I mean arguably okay so what would
happen if there was a message generated
in the case where the interval is too
far off from the series is that
obviously wrong I think we need some
sort of blending of the type
you are suggesting my worry is that
because this will be use used by by some
students who have to follow strictly
some formulas they may get some results
sometimes which do not agree with the
formulas they collect give them a
message so give them a message saying
you know the the using something else
because the interval will give a stupid
result I mean because the the series
would give a stupid result going beyond
first order because first order would be
I mean I don't know exactly how we want
to say it but essentially what it boils
down to its first order would be
misleading I see I see so somehow rather
than saying that the default is order
one would say that the default is
automatic I would choose it for you
that's correct but if we only do that if
it's going to be a stupid result right
so in other words I think the only case
that we should really error out on is
the case where we're going to give a
zero it's this case so flat derivative I
I think this is the only to my mcwhat
from what I can see here this is the
only totally misleading case is the case
where we go from one around to a naked
number for example there are error there
are users complaining about around not
handling discontinuities like in a
rounding step function and these are
cases so what the heck are you supposed
to do in that case exactly exactly so
what do they want it to do I mean if
they're complaining they probably say it
should do this they always expect
interval arithmetic so the exact dude
you need to be aware they expect us to
be aware of the jump and make around
respond to exactly to jump yeah I can't
tell that I mean the cosine thing also
seeing I'll just put in here the cosine
thing also seems wrong in that you're
not getting I mean you know cosine is
not symmetric around zero it's it's
always less than equal to walk so what's
your point
my point is that the interval given
shouldn't shouldn't exceed one but
that's not what you get in the
first-order formalism first tilde
formalism is blind to the fact that
there's a you know the the the domain of
the function is limited yeah fine I'm
just saying if we if we go beyond the
first-order formalism we should we
should incorporate the domain of the
function as well the range of the
function as well gets complicated
so right now they so we can describe
asymmetric errors with a rod but right
now they do not do not appear
automatically so again
yeah we will be saying we will introduce
them with when needed look the fact is
if we generated an error a message in
the case where there's zero derivative
or the case where within the you know
within the range described by around
there is a discontinuity in the function
both of which things we know then that
would go a long way to solving this
problem I think well yes but but for
example if I take a round of you know
cosine X around of say you know one
tenth the comma three you're still
centering yourself around that around
that zero derivative point I mean I
don't understand how the formalism works
but you smell that sort of what the
formalism says you do I mean the
formalism is is what it is and I you
know trouble is there's a slippery slope
because you know you not you don't even
know in the input you know it's yes you
don't know from the input what they mean
when they say plus minus whatever you
know they certainly didn't know that it
was a Gaussian distribution and and have
all these special properties it's just
this this vague statement of the you
know 1 1 plus or minus 0.2 or something
um all right anyway I think we should
play have a separate meeting about this
but I think that
I mean my take is if we can at least
detect when something is going horribly
wrong and generate a message that will
be a significant part of the battle
doing something better automatically
would also be good but by the time
there's a message people know there's a
problem okay so alright fine don't be
experimental eyes but hopefully by the
next version we will be able to do
experimental eyes that look at this this
is another one where it's being
recommended to keep it experimental okay
Rob why do you want to keep n body
simulation experimental okay so
basically I think you know I think the
inverted that the proper invitation of
this uses a fast multipole method yes we
don't have a fast multipole method okay
but so what I mean so that experimental
ization or not is not a question of what
the implementation is it's a question
what the design is so is there something
wrong with the design I haven't seen too
many complaints about the design the the
other aspect that's that's missing is we
basically have this very limited set of
you know set of potentials and stuff
which we've got with physics knowledge
like yeah Michael type person to to fill
in well I understand that but these are
limitations these are not you know
design problems yeah but but do we do we
unexperienced multiple things we talked
about that multiple times before we
really really need to get those but um
you know it's a question
yeah um
well okay um I don't see why we
shouldn't be experimental eyes it if
unless you think there's a problem with
the design
I don't think let me just look at them
let me see what box okay you know what
you know what we should leave it for now
I mean I but but for goodness sake let's
try and make it by the next version
let's try and make sure that we have
looked at this and hopefully we will
have some fast multipole capability by
them yeah it would be yeah I think you
know I mean I I wouldn't mind looking at
that working on good other things to do
too which I understand I understand but
can you at least scope out our difficult
it is I'm sure or do you already know
the answer to that I think it's I think
it's moderately difficult okay all right
you know what the most important thing
would be scope it out to the point where
we can do a design and then make sure
that that design does not tangle with
the existing design of n-body simulation
if it doesn't then I think we can do
experimental eyes and body simulation
okay science well how do we know the
path to getting the faster
implementation okay okay okay let's go
back okay thank you rob Thank You Jose I
think that's it for both of you and let
me lose the background noise as well
okay thanks guys
Hey okay let's start at the top now
oh boy
really has anybody actually used these
and had them work Oh what do you mean
like I mean it works every time I try to
use it it gets tangled up oh right yes
so here's the thing I have read on the
back end of this actually so now it is
do you want me to go into details or yes
okay so here are a couple of issues I
map as a protocol is we don't have any
good stuff to parse the messages that
are coming from IMAP so which made it a
little bit difficult so I was trying to
do clever things like look at the
envelope our said blah blah blah and the
result is that if we just get the whole
message if you download the whole
message things work a lot better because
we have EML info that is very robust as
far as I can tell I mean it has some
issues with HTML and whatnot but overall
it is quite solid and now we have also
implemented caching systems there once
you download a message or you request a
message it is there on the desk okay can
I ask you a question do you know if
Roger is using this capability for my
mail process uh I don't think so okay
cuz I haven't told him that it is
already there so no no but I mean the
whole system is it being used for
processing my mail or not no okay that's
how a huge confidence because I know
that things that we wanted to do that um
for which we thought this was going to
be a solution I think it is a much
better solution now sorry if he gets a
new build and stops using it it will be
extremely and especially in the front
and it actually now provides you with a
some water for feedback what it is doing
in the backend so you're not just
waiting for it without any knowledge
that if something is happening or not
you see because we are downloading
messages and there was no feedback so
you see you had this concept of
functions returning progress indicators
functions that take a while and okay so
if I do I just connected to my mail
server okay and if I do something if I
want to go into a particular folder what
do I do
Oh present inbox no I don't want the
inbox or whatever your name is
take whatever junk if you have a junk
folder no I'm talking about so I do it
with the slashes and everything I know
you just need to give it the name that
is no no no no no no no I've got a
folder that's cool to do slash something
slash something yeah then you'd have to
give it that name okay
so I say oh come on
isn't there a mail folder list that
gives you all yes I I've got the mail
folder list okay and I'm doing
well so for example here I've got some
some folders here yes so you could just
copy paste not yeah I did that I didn't
hand it on work right so take this one
now I sure I want to take this one okay
I say percent twelve
could not be found well sure looked like
it was there okay there is a mail folder
association property could you grab that
I'll take a look at it maybe I can do
something better over there that's gonna
give me for every one of my yes and then
you can just save it and get the fold
out of it if it's not working by just
giving out okay okay
okay so there I've got a mail folder yes
and do now we're pending on what build
it is I only put it in the suspense with
1200 build okay in 12 Oh is rubbish
sorry but you can do present one and it
will grab you the first email in that
yeah
okay but now in 12:1 it actually saves
it and
what if it's big and has giant
attachments the attachments can't be
more than two 20 megabytes I believe not
in our particular mail system I don't
know what it is for other people's mail
systems but I all the major ones have
some limitations to it and yes it will
save it to the disk and that's a good
thing because you're going to have to
work on it I don't see it was harder to
just figure out what the right thing to
do is than doing the simple thing and
moving forward with that right okay look
I think we need to okay we had had
for example okay the thing I want to do
is when there's a male thread for
instance visualizing the threads in my
mail can we do that from this it is
completely built on a MLM per se if a
yellow import can do it this can do it
also no no no I'm asking the
practicality of you know as a practical
matter if I've got a thousand pending
mails can I visualize the thread
structure of those planning mails as a
practical matter or will it take you
know six years to do it it can do an
impractical amount of time okay okay let
me ask you another question if I've got
uh let's see this is not I guess an
active mailbox question what is this
question I mean when I've sent somebody
a piece of mail and they don't respond
and they should respond right we run a
classifier it says the mail I sent to
them is something which asks for a
response we wait X amount of time a week
they don't respond um you know can we
tell that what how would we tell that is
that from here or is that more from the
you know from something that has to look
at a mail archive it will have to be
something that looks at the mail archive
otherwise I mean you can check for flags
but otherwise what happens on your end
but I this is no no I understand but
what I'm looking for is let's imagine no
no no in my sent mail folder right is a
mail message okay yeah it says um hey
Fahim can you figure out this than that
yes okay then we should be able to do
the logic of figuring out that no I
didn't get a response to that message
the machine learning classifier says
that message is one that asks for a
response yep okay okay but
you know so the question is something
like that is it doable with this or is
it gonna get all tangled up
I tell me that will be an automatic
thing that runs oh I don't know
couple of times a day that goes and
snarfs in stuff from the sent messages
right and probably things that are a
year old a dead meat nothing's gonna
happen with them I guess
gonna have some logic I think that would
be a good example I mean can you think
of another example of I mean there'll be
a good test case which is also up would
happen to be very useful to me at least
right and with this I think it will be
the way the caching works and the fact
that it is all organized yes it should
be very easy nowadays ok let's try it
ok so because we do caching yes now it
is possible okay maybe maybe you can
work with Roger to see if you can get
that to happen that is fine
I think it should be working yes I think
that the the main thing I I don't know
whether we did have some effort to make
a classifier for messages that require a
response ok ok I mean I definitely think
we can do that probably for external
messages there's a pretty decent
heuristic that if there's an external
message sent um it is very likely that
it requested a response yeah ok so let's
try that before we do experimental eyes
this stuff because I'm I'm not convinced
yet ok fair enough
um ok now you're also on for cookie
management is that correct yes what is
happening here well I mean nothing is
happening here it has been dead for
however since we introduced it the idea
behind it was that dollar cookie store
is a file based record system so
multiple kernels we we didn't have a
proper answer for it what happens if
there are because it's actually a file
and if you have multiple kernel sessions
than read and write might cause an issue
but I'm not so there's no ethnicity to
the cookie store
yeah ah okay so it's always like so so
the issue is when URL read read
something it is reading it is getting
cookies
saved during that reading process yes
and the question is where is where is
that where are those cookies because
it's an indirect operation URL read does
what it does and indirectly it's saving
away cookies right okay and the
challenge is um where does it put those
cookies yes and that we depend on so
this is not a home-baked system the
cookie store a we borrow it from let
coal which is the underlying library for
it okay we're fine but it's but so it
doesn't have atomicity either No
okay and what is the relationship
between the cookie store and a
persistent value like if I wanted to put
the cookie store in my if I wanted to
really persist it across my whole
account by having it in the cloud and so
on is that a realistic thing to want to
do probably not just because of the
security issues but avoiding that I I
think it would be hard to do that but
not impossible I I just have now sought
all the details so okay so the issue is
multiple kernels reading in the same
account writing cookie store data that
you know stomps on top of it other ones
yes
what a mess I mean I the clearly there's
some hacks forgetting anti-missile no
the right thing to do is database
systems that can be accessed by multiple
applications and whatnot well right
which we're about to have right so maybe
cookie store should eventually turn into
an entity store which is backed by a
database it's very elaborate for
something that's rather obscure
precisely and so we have sort of all
right fine leave it is experimental for
now so the dependency there will be once
this can be so the answer but by the way
I'm sorry we failed to implement the
thing that we were supposed to implement
here which is the Raj were you not
around for this the the writing the
sentences that explain why something is
being left experimental we are coming up
with the system to do so I'm just
finalizing that for Brian so okay it
isn't in place yet but it'll be for the
next voice next time so I mean for
example for this you know for n-body we
should say we're not experimental izing
it pending faster underlying algorithms
which might change the design but
they're improving we should say we're
not experimental izing because it's
pending understanding the relationship
between axiom systems and based logics
numbers with uncertainty we should say
we're not experimental izing because of
this point that we can explain to do
with zero derivative you know functions
or or discontinuous functions okay
they'll functionality we're not be
experimental izing because we feel it
hasn't been adequately tested in the
wild right I'll maintain separate notes
but we'll also have a poor function you
know the reasons documented in the
documentation page as you requested fine
okay I don't know what connection
settings even is what is it it's an
option oh boy
why is it
what what I mean seems like a reasonable
thing or whether the name connection
settings I mean I think we intended that
to be a more general thing that
interestingly could be used I mean
something like this could be reused in
connection with throttling API usage and
things couldn't it
max download speed max upload speed I
don't maybe maybe not but I mean those
that this class of names okay so for
example a question for cloud objects
maybe there should be a connection
settings for cloud objects that defines
these things as well so if somebody has
a one gigabyte cloud object um you can
define you should be able to define for
users what the max download speed of
that is and so on maybe this wrong said
people in this meeting but can can
somebody take that - I guess it's Joel
and Matt who are thinking about cloud
object and all of the various
permissions related restrictions on
cloud objects okay they're also thinking
about the the abuse blocking for cloud
objects user controllable abuse blocking
yes I made a note yes okay very good
all right okay next up this there's no
way this one is going to escape here by
the time we got a decimal by Sun running
around no this is before we talked about
that last then I I talked to Carlo and
he's out the beginning of this week
they're trying to see if we can fit the
whole [ __ ] thing into the entity
framework it's a bit difficult because
the whole long thing is no SQL I
understand I mean I but I think the
future is it's going to be widely used
in the system that's what we have to do
the only question is for this you know
is there a [ __ ] um Africa mistake this
is so pathetic
the search is so pathetic can you report
that bug as well
I can't yes um
so I mean the issue is for something
like this [ __ ] collection name I mean I
have no idea whether this package is
mature I guess this package is a
one-to-one correspondence to the [ __ ]
interface they're the official [ __ ]
interface so the point is that is do we
want to build something on top of this
if so then this is at you because this
has everything already do we want to
change this I guess this is the point
you'd want to change we don't know and
we won't know until we try to build
something on top of it we first we built
something that was a ml data framework
it works fairly well I understand that I
understand that we are currently trying
to productize that yep right let's wait
until we productize that to the
experimental eyes this okay and maybe we
also wait till we I had the proper
thorough discussion with Carlo Barbieri
about how to integrate this with the
entity store if we can it's not a way
because I had a meeting with him this
morning but anyway who knows no he's
aware I talked to him last last week ok
ok fine all right
then who was I talking to this morning I
was talking to him anyway I'm confused
doesn't really what what did you ask him
well I we we had a meeting about
databases this morning oh yeah but I
mean he told me like oh we gonna discuss
this next week because ok fine oh it
doesn't have time ok fine
um ok ok well sadly and yet another
nandi experimental eyes thing um and I
think for these packages it it's some do
we need to explain why we're not the
experimental icing packages that's sort
of a policy issue that's not I I don't
think we should unless we have something
interesting to say I don't think we
should need to need to express an
opinion about that Oh
scheduled tasks
for goodness sake okay so we have
constant in here do we have anybody else
representing J job tasks do we have
constant in here yes you were to leave
the whole thing experimental okay what
is reasons and to wit what are the
reasons so loco submit it has to have an
option way to initialize the corral a
simple simple thing that if you if you
want to counter so the task of leads to
increase of the content X plus plus but
you need to set the initial value and
there is no way I'm sorry so you're
saying there is a design imperfection in
this yes so for example you do local
submit of X plus plus which should
increase the value but you have no way
to initialize X okay so wave it so this
is a design flaw but I mean why hasn't
this come up in the discussion of just
designed for the tasks in general it did
not come up in social submit because you
share all the name space so passing down
passing the returning cloud submit it
would come up in could be didn't yeah
why not I mean it's the same issue and
if I say cloud submit X plus plus is
could just go bonkers yeah I think it
was oversight
okay so what is your proposal for how to
do the design for the initializer maybe
it should have an option initial
Alliance or something like that about
what to do for many point well what do
we do that we will what we do there is
what do we do
initialization fair enough okay so what
you're proposing then is that lets say
clouds submit I don't understand this
and understand why isn't the
initialization just part of the expert
here although look at the second line
[Music]
submits is a task to evaluate or gets
were in total on schedule but there
isn't you cannot you have to pass
somewhere your skills what are you
talking about I'm sorry I don't
understand if experts X plus plus yeah
this is a crazy thing anyway
what does this mean what what is local
submitted X plus plus possibly mean it's
a colder you just let the other great
you just let story somewhere how can X
be persistent
how would you persist X unless you use
persistent value to do it for as long as
dusk is running no X is there and it's
persistent but you said local submit of
a particular function oh I see in the
task persisting it in the task yeah how
on earth does that you can you can have
the task reportedly where you're back
but how does it work in the cloud when
there's a task I don't understand this
so the task object comes back but hasn't
aren't all the resources associated with
the execution of that task they are gone
in the cloud when you exit aren't they
yes but for as long as dusk is running
what what does it mean running I mean it
could be running for a year but only
wake up once a month
couldn't it you know could be yes okay
so how does that work in the cloud in
the cloud it's using the scheduled tasks
bass is that right to maintain these
these tasks I cannot speak well maybe
somebody should should be able to talk
about that so local submit would have to
persist in the local object store or
something
the thing that you
whatever was the no it doesn't have to
personal uh yeah basically is so it has
to persist for as long as task is
earning yes and so the value of access
stored one day on the secondary coronal
not I don't son if I do a local submit
okay hold on I mean I'm not confused if
I do repeated local submits I don't seem
to have an argument to local submit that
says submit it to the same task
I mean local submit is a fire-and-forget
thing it submits the separately
encapsulated task that does what it does
hmm so I understand how X plus plus can
be used as a counter no it's correct so
X was possible range this expression but
X has to be said before the task is
running I know but it's not a counter
because the thing doesn't come back
after the task finishes the X plus plus
has returned its value if I'm working
through handlers it can be report back
any time
ex-excuse increased I understand that
but I'm saying that it's a one-shot deal
it doesn't re does it
I mean local submit no I say when the
task has finished its things are gone
yes okay hold on the X plus plus case in
a scheduled tasks
the problem is each scheduled task is in
general starting from a kernel which is
a fresh kernel is that correct yes okay
but the X that was in that previous
kernel is long gone unless it persists
externally it's long gone yes okay so I
don't understand what you're talking
about there is a submit or try to this X
equal to 1 and then sessions have need x
plus plus or print X oh I know I
realized that I realized that in this
session you have local shared memory you
have access to X to the value of x so
local sub needs should do the same
except we outsource the execution to
different kernel but the different
kernel has not has no access to this
local X and you cannot pass it there so
the only exit could have access to is
something persistently stored in local
object store correct currently yes but
you can you should be able to pass it as
initialization why not
it doesn't exist I understand that but
you know how do you reach back so you do
one X plus plus okay from one local
submitted boss okay now in that local
submit you may say initialization x
equals seven
yes now after the X plus plus the
initialization should be x equals eight
but you wanna know this length so what
can you store in X will be will be eight
yes locally stored where in the task in
the corner that's running the task okay
fine then you can fire a handle function
to report the writing back I understand
that but as soon as that kernel for
whatever reason I mean local submit has
no guarantee that a particular kernel a
local submit of a scheduled task that's
running for a decade has no guarantee
that's the same kernel that's running
every instance of the scheduled task in
local submit does now in local community
every task runs in its own kernel
okay fine and I'm fine but then again
I'm asking you again the question of how
does the value of X get
moved between Colonels I don't see how
it will doesn't that's what does the
whole point you can't
but the only way you're going to be able
to do this is to write an atomic file
somewhere that can be reread by a
different kernel no no when I when I
start there
the secondary corn off to run the task I
can pass all the values through math
link but there is no it's not syntax for
that well wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait when you start the talk
again you can pass the values but how do
you get back the roast recent values for
functions okay but so the initialization
but listen listen you give the
initialization once at the time when
you're setting up the task you know that
initialization that you have given
cannot be changed the installation is
done once before the task is around you
don't have to change it you can change
the local variables which were local
variables local variables but where are
you storing the non-local the global
variables that will be used in these
local kernels
start in the in the separate colonel no
there's no colonel running there's no
colonel that persistently runs right so
if you're gonna store something long
term between Colonels
it's got to be stored in a persistent
value nothing I think you're slightly
confusing the issue there's no
consistency here
it's a tasks that you start it's done
and it's finished
there's no persistence okay so what does
X plus plus do it will increase the
value of x but what is X
currently it will just generate X plus
plus infinite the ones for as long as
it's there it's symbolic well I
understand but how do you give a value
for x that come in it okay if you had an
initialization option right then you say
local submit with a scheduled task you
give initialization in the local submit
yeah I would say installation arrow and
then I will say X equal to seven and
that would be passed to the secondary
corner which would ever leave that I
understand yes
which creates an X which is now eight
but only in the secondary kernel yes
yes so when the secretary colonel dies
the X which is set to eight goes poof
yes yes the initial say yes I don't see
a problem was that that's the task yes
it's what is it to say x equals seven
why is because it's gonna report the
back using handlers you could okay then
why isn't it just this
why aren't you typing x equals 7x plus
plus why isn't it equivalent to that
what is the difference between that and
saying local submit of X plus plus
initialization arrow because the whole
the whole expression x equal to 7 so my
column X plus plus use a related every
time
but every time do you mean every time to
schedule tasks or you mean every time
the schedule task is running on their
own the second good oh but how can it do
anything different because the different
instances that the schedule class could
be separated by a year it doesn't matter
as long as the kernel is running but it
won't be running for a year it's not
going to be running for a year four loko
submitted Festo otherwise it's not that
you should send information for or cause
of me and the con was running all the
time okay so you say given a session
there is a pet kernel that it creates
that will be the local submit kernel is
that right yes yes
okay so but the original session dies
then it's pet dies with it so to speak
yes okay so I'm totally confused so
within one I mean I understand your
point now that within one outer session
so to speak that having an
initialization every time you run local
submit it will ignore the initialization
it's a once basically I mean I don't
understand why it's not the same thing
as saying rather than having an
initialization saying you know once X
equals 7x plus plus because I what I see
is an expression which is once X or X
equal to 70 semicolon X was passed and I
don't know where the that whole thing
should be related once or butBut it says
it says the x equals 7 is evaluated once
the whole thing is evaluated however
locals submit evaluates what it's
supposed to evaluate
in the simple application yes I can look
at once and do that but being if it's
getting wood I know my haters yeah I'm
not buying this I'm confused is there
anybody else here understand what what's
going on have you tried to sell us to
Todd I I did not think I did not
invented this people came up with it
they said how to initialize action by
saying I'm away okay I think this is a
confusion I think they should be using
once inside their actual code I mean I
don't think it's necessarily harmful to
have this initialization think it's
gonna be exactly equivalent to using
once inside the code I think we're
trying to in the way to make unusual
Micek is used elsewhere because in
association are you fine but once exists
elsewhere also fine okay you know what
try and sell this to Todd and we are
over time and we should really go and
unfortunately we have in this meeting we
have completely failed today
experimental eyes anything there is
another issue with tasks which I would
like to bring because I'm trying to
bring it up all the time and it's not
working yes okay but we're really late
okay keep it short tasks it tells it
gives the list of front asks and I think
it is wrong that tasks also gives the
list of tasks of local tasks and task on
the cloud which is called object I think
this is wrong
there should be two functions reason is
that if I do local calculations which
involves evaluating tasks in relating
something else you should not reach the
cloud every time tasks related it should
be should stay local so you're arguing
for local tasks and cloud tasks function
something like that yes I don't have a
strong opinion it doesn't seem obviously
wrong it is this design is wrong because
reaching for the cloud takes a lot of
time and if I need tasks to be quickly
related
only one task is running tough cramming
it just slows down the whole competition
for no reason you should be separate it
doesn't seem obviously wrong to me but I
mean I don't understand maybe we need
then a session tasks local task loud
tasks or an option to task which was
separate but it should not just blindly
report all the tasks so it could be
tasks of cloud or something could be
yeah or drops of clouds in it all right
can we bring that up in an it's a
perfectly sensible thing can you get
that another I'll do LCC meeting yep I
can bring that up okay all right um so
we need some text for why tasks isn't
being de experiment lized
and this really probably is not well
Oh everything else is kind of I can't
see much use so I cannot say well I mean
you wouldn't necessarily know but yes
okay
I have a only bought two functions
okay all right um yeah by the way to end
the second oh yeah um
second and our livestream is asking why
would you not use local submit instead
of session submit do you want to
reference a temporary variable because
session submit Ilocos admit there are no
different corals local submit is a
separate colonel session submit is using
your session colonel if you use la casa
mental then you have a reason to use
presumably yeah because you wanted to
run in an ER separately from their main
colonel all right okay very good
this meeting was useful even though we
did not successfully do experimental
eyes anything um all right thanks to
folks here thanks to folks on the
livestream be back a different time see
you later